there's their small things I can think
of straight off the bat but for instance
like I remember growing gap and my
mother always saying never cut your
fingernails after dark and I eyes to the
state probably have never cut my
fingernails after dark and I thought
about it I researched this a little bit
it doesn't appear in my novel but I was
interested in why I want earth do a lot
of iranians think that you can't cut
your fingernails after dark and the
origin I believe of this superstition is
it was in the era pre electricity you
know people would actually get hurt you
know utilizing scissors and cutting
their you know fingernails or toenails
or whatever in the dark or with kerosene
lamps or whatever they used I don't I
don't know but it seemed to me that that
was the reason and and I I love that I
love that sort of folklore but there's
tons of stuff like that I mean I grew up
as a child completely neurotic because
of all these things my parents would
tell me is ancient cultural voodoo that
was always sort of present in her
household and it made me very very
stressed out as a child how do you merge
that was sort of modern living and
trying to assimilate to this new world
that you're in and it was very difficult
for me you know I was very cognizant of
learning English in the US and I was it
was a very harrowing for me because I
was always trying to sort of fit in and
do it fast before anyone can notice the
difference
but you know the minute someone kids
would meet my parents you know or the
minute they entered the picture it
seemed like they would just unravel my
whole my whole guy's a bad bit so I was
always a little bit at odds with them
and I think that that is definitely
explored ad nauseam in the book
you